hey what up it's one only Mr
Thanksgiving CEO of Generation Now
creative gangster girls Grammy
award-winning Yours Truly DJ Drama I'm
really like that new album please make
sure you get that and I'm on the bootleg
cab podcast why wouldn't I be
like half show we got DJ Drama in here
yeah welcome way to start it's been a
long time in the making yeah I mean I
went to uh Atlanta during the pandemic
and we kind of did like a little
generation now yep but yeah you being
here yeah it's about [__] time I feel
like I've been stalking you it felt I
mean well never that I mean you're my
guy yo drum when you coming on the
[__] show you're in La all the time
yeah it has and I I have been putting it
off for some time but I have reason to
be here I got a [__] new album new
album single you know what I mean I
wanted to be I wanted to be timely and I
knew a conversation with you is is you
know significant you know what I'm
saying for sure well I do say DJ Drama
is the greatest hip-hop DJ of all time
it's big the greatest of all time I'm
not saying it so scratching and [__]
transforming and [__] but you're the
greatest you're the goat so hold on let
me thank you first of all so if they're
making a
for 50 years of hip-hop and they make a
DJ list like of the greatest DJs in 50
years you're putting me I don't even
think it's a discussion wow
I mean I it would be hard for me to
agree
um humbly
I would like to be in the top five but
if we talk about 50 years we're talking
Jazzy Jeff we talking Jeff no no no now
listen I'm talking about listen cause
Jazzy Jeff probably
like like there's guys who are really
good at DJing yeah party rockers [__]
I mean we can go on and there's like
some but I just think when I think of
like
your cultural impact on the last 20
years of rap music
it is literally not even a discussion
nobody has ever impacted hip-hop culture
as a DJ the way you have and I don't
even think and like listen you can go
back to cool herk was cool herk a DJ or
a rapper it was a DJ he was a DJ okay so
he kind of started it yeah but I'm
talking about bro I'm [__] 36. so
when I was coming up it was Funk Flex I
had like the 60 Minutes of Funk [__]
um I was getting DJ Clue tapes and then
when I started bootlegging [__] and
selling [__] at the Swap Meet it was
like all great gangster girl [__] but
we're talking about your fingerprints
are all over
it all
Jeezy Wayne Pharrell Gucci
you just want to [__] Grammy with
Tyler the Creator bruh you put a you won
a Grammy with a gangster grills what are
we talking about
a gangster girls want a Grammy
I've done some [__] man I'm really like
that I really think that like people can
say what they want like I mean people
there's been even artists there's been a
guy like listen DJ Khaled for sure has
put out bigger songs than you as an
artist right right
but like
I forget the name of the Lil Wayne DJ
Khaled tape but it wasn't that big of a
deal like it had a gym on there though
but you remember which tape I'm talking
about yeah it was called the [__] this
the rehab or the the suffix the suffix
suffix suffix yeah the suffix but we're
talking about the dedication yeah yeah
we're talking about dedication we're
talking do you just like I mean even
like [__] like little brothers Gangsta
Grill like just so many like your
fingerprints are everywhere like you
just told me a story about your first
tape with Gucci
were you removed Nicki Minaj's verse
because she wasn't popping yet
oh God why are we talking about this
Nikki I apologize so what happened
um me and Gucci's first actual gangster
girls we actually did one with Yo Gotti
first it was called definition of a g
that was the first tape me in uh Gucci
had did together it was collaboration
Gotti Gucci and me the first official
Gucci Man gangster girls was called the
movie
and when he brought it to me the first
song that was for the tape the first
voice you heard on the S on the tape was
Nicki Minaj obviously this is a uh early
Nicki Minaj and
disrespectfully you know I felt like
we can't have a gangster girls with me
and Gucci and the first voice you hear
not be Gucci so I removed her
um perverse perverse from that song I
feel terrible to this day did she know
it was your decision
um
I don't know she she may know now but in
defense I will say that
I made sure out of everyone that Nicki
Minaj was on dedication three because
Nicki Minaj was about to get left off of
dedication three she was calling me
directly cedram please don't let the
tape come out without me on there and I
said I got you so Nicki Minaj is on
dedication three directly because I made
short she was on there so so you got it
came back I'm trying to make it up I'm
trying to you know did anyone ever hear
the Nikki verse that you remember did
you ever use it anywhere else did that I
don't I really don't know I don't know
whatever came from that we'd have to
probably ask Gucci do you still have
like your OG email access I wish I had a
gangster girls.com Gmail that was
probably just some [__] in there
so crazy I used to get these [__]
Beats
from this like random email from like it
was like boy idea or something like I
was like who is this boy idea sending me
all these beats like in like 0506 you
should flood my email because you know
how to pronounce the name it's a weird
name and now looking back why wasn't it
yeah it was Boy Wonder I've told him
that I've definitely we've talked about
that like [__] was crazy yeah cause I
just think about like even the last two
or three years the research like if you
think about it we went through this
weird cycle where the blogs would drop
the no DJ version of mixtapes as well as
the DJ versions of mixtapes and I
remember you having an issue with that
and
um I felt used yeah because they would
use the gangster girl's brand yeah to
like launch it and then like a week
later they would drop like a no DJ
version without your [__] on it yeah
like what the [__] but now we like kind
of like came back around now everybody
is getting the gangster grills and
they're dropping them on dsps like I
mean shots Jeep Rico you guys just
dropped that one
there was a day recently where I feel
like you had three tapes come out in one
day and one day I dropped Jesus snowfall
Snoop and NBA young boy that was crazy
like I was like on the that was like
right after I won DJ of the year or two
with the hip-hop Awards
I was like oh yeah I'm coming from
coming for the next year's award how
like how much do you feel like because
if people don't know you're also uh you
like and Don have cultivated a label
called generation now that has two of
the biggest superstars in hip-hop period
at the moment Jack Harlow and little Uzi
yes
um so you've obviously been
busy yeah you've been put you've also
put out records you've been you've been
listen it's like you've never went
anywhere but do you feel like the Tyler
album
sparked the gangster grills Resurgence
thousand percent
thousand percent you gotta gotta tip
your head off to you know I saw someone
say like of all people who would have
thought Tyler the Creator who of people
have called a weirdo for thus long would
bring gangster girls back to life like
yeah I mean one just the ingenious idea
of him of the the concept of him making
his album against the girls and
utilizing me the way it did and two
obviously us winning a Grammy like come
on you can't you can't deny
like Tyler had a lot to do with it and I
still think that that like
you know just even recently I saw like
Benny and Westside Gunn uh make some
references like yo we got drama out of
his executive bag like you know even
before Tyler I had I had did the BSF
[__] I did BSF [__] I did some [__] on
guns project so you know there there
were some other projects you know out
there so I think like
um they're you know clearly like as a
brand gangster girls was still strong
but I think you know the the the
response and just what Tyler's album did
like really that's we have a lot to
thank for that for sure like or even the
Jeezy snowfall like that was in the
works by the way the best cheesy album
and I don't know what are we thinking 10
years sometime it's been it's been a
while I was like yeah we were in New
York riding around listening to that
[__] when it came out I was like God
damn cheesy back on his [__] yeah and uh
I had that feel and then you guys were
doing the shows together yeah that was
fun that was that was dope that was a
good time so when Tyler hits you up
because obviously
you're you're you're extremely
culturally aware I don't like I feel
like some people might think oh DJ Drama
just knows what's popping in the strip
club whatever but like you know what's
up so like 100 Tyler reaches out to you
I'm sure you know how big this can be
because Igor was he huge oh yeah I mean
without question I mean
I knew I remember you know
because we started it in 2020 during the
pandemic so I was doing like Zoom
interviews and calls and I knew it was
it was coming and like you know
obviously I couldn't talk about it but I
was like yo I got some big [__] coming
no I think during our interview you like
alluded to something coming yeah but you
can talk about I couldn't talk about it
but Lake even the the session that he
came to lake lake came to the second
session
um we did we did like three or four
um his first was the second session and
when he heard the music like off top he
was like you know I think he's gonna win
a Grammy for this I said it just plain
and simple clears day like I think he's
gonna win a Grammy kind of like he
called it are the songs already done and
then you get brought in to like
collaborate with him on like the [__]
you're gonna say yeah like what's that
process like album's done and then you
come in after or are you like in there
when he's recording any verses like yeah
for the most part it was done I mean
Tyler's so genius and creative like he
had already when he first came up with
the idea he had taken random DJ Drama
vocals from like another project and
they put him on there placed it on like
where he thought I should talk or what
it would sound like just so he could
hear it and then like you know we we
vibed a lot like we sat in the studio
and talked and just talked music and you
know vision and things like that he told
me you know what his what the concept
and where he wanted to go and just about
life the last couple years and you know
that's literally how I like to work too
like a lot of you know what I what I
like to say on projects or you know the
direction I go I like to work off of you
know I mean I'm I feel like it's an art
in its own sense so you know I work off
of
um inspiration and then
um yeah I would go in the booth and I
would I would say some [__] and play
around and then he would like kind of
like be like yo like say like I'm on a
boat and I'll be like I'm on a boat yeah
he'd be like oh my God it's [__]
crazy and like you know talk about like
um having my toes out and [__] like that
so you know he was that that was one
that you know a lot of times when I Do
tapes I I normally like to do them in my
own Zone but obviously it was like
collaborative very collaborative and but
you know I mean he's a he's a one-man
Army so you know production like
everything he does it all so a lot of a
lot of it he had had done but then
during the session some of the music
changed but even while I was in there he
was still kind of like working on
production and you know going in and
things like that it's crazy too because
one of your more underappreciated
projects was the one with Pharrell it's
like kind of a cult classic but that
kind of ended up being like there's no
call me if you get lost if there's no
Pharrell tape yeah but it's but you know
to me or in my travels like the way
dedication and trap or die is to certain
people the Pharrell tape is to certain
people like I've had a lot of it's like
a cult classic it is and I've had a lot
of a lot of people from
a certain like you know like hipster
kids or just like
you know not not the what you would
think the normal gangster girls listen
or like come up and like yo that
Pharrell tape changed my life like the
Pharrell gangster girls was like it was
this for me like so and artists too like
that was definitely one of those ones
and obviously that was a big inspiration
for somebody like Tyler growing up so
yeah that was that was that was a big
that was a big tape for me I mean
because you know at the time Pharrell
was already like a god you know what I'm
saying of course so when I was when he
was on a skateboard P Vibes like when
when I got that phone call like y'all I
think I you know that I think that's the
only mixtape he's ever done in his
career you know what I'm saying so for
us for me to be a part of that and when
I got that call and then just like you
know just that's that's one of those
tapes that definitely is one of the the
greatest ever like you know the way it's
put together the Zone I was in like and
[__] was incredible
for you
how because I'm I'm assuming nowadays if
if a major label artist wants a gangsta
grills one you have to [__] with the
music but two they have to have the back
they're not no one's getting the
gangster girls I'm assuming is that fair
to say
oh you have to be cut in on the project
in some aspect yeah the way that the I
mean because like
things have changed
uh in the music business it's not the
same way it used to be no it's not the
same way so there's you know the the way
that we approach the business has
changed and elevated
um the the cost of the gangster grills
is
not what it was in the mid 2000s but you
get a cut
um I get I get more you should get
something yeah there's more than just a
check involved right right for sure some
residual income there absolutely in the
in your Peak though what was the biggest
bag you ever got
to do a gangster grills because you had
some random ass Gangsta grills floating
around
yeah I did and it was obviously like
this I know what this one was I think it
probably was Pro to be honest it
probably came from an athlete it
probably was like a good like in in the
earlier days it was it was a maybe like
a 40 piece or something like 40 cater to
the gangster girls was it for like the
athletes rapper yeah was this which
athlete Carmelo Anthony
um Maury Stoudemire I did do one I did
it I actually did do one for Carmelo
sounds about right that it wasn't that
one but I've done some I've done some
very notable uh remember KD had his
thing going yeah we never did again by
that point I don't
think Katie never came to me for against
the grills
um
um but uh shout to KD though I know 40
bands ain't bad checks in but yeah I've
done you know Jason Terry
DeSean Jackson Jason Terry Sante Samuels
uh uh meta shot the meadow World Peace
Ron Artest has a gangster girls where
he's actually rapping on there of course
of course he does yeah
Steven Steven Jackson yep
and uh we got some there's some more out
there too you were running it up
it's a fun time a fun time indeed my boy
V the ruler I know had one early from
you like from Phoenix and I know he paid
for it but V's like my dog so I remember
like I hosted his next tape and he's
like yeah I got a whole project with DJ
drum I'm like
DJ Drama knows you though but that was
probably what was that like
2013 12. okay but yeah man so this new
album uh you got the new single with hey
boogie who else a little baby little
baby
[Music]
um
what's the name of the album uh uh I'm
really like that I'm really like that
yeah
for you are you taking like because
there is one thing about DJ projects
that can get hairy and usually they
don't sound very cohesive
usually it just sounds like songs it's
like a bunch of songs crammed in with
the hottest of hot it's not very
cohesive yeah you get to hit singles off
of them yeah but if I'm pressing play
from start to finish that's why I got to
give it up to Metro Boomin and I know
he's not a DJ he's a producer yeah but
the way he curated his album incredible
it's [__] insane what approach did
you take for this something similar
where I wanted to make a cohesive body
of work
from beginning to end where it was an
album not of just songs but you know
something that people would put on
at the top and you know and let it ride
and let it ride and like you know
interesting collaborations not just
necessarily like Chase names like you
know just artists that I think are dope
that I would love and wanted to hear
together and like you know great voices
and great production and like you know
really make a good body work I feel like
this is my best body of work since uh
quality Street Music the my quality
Street Music one which came out about 10
years ago so that was was that the one
that had the Jeremiah recording
no that was my yeah yep yeah my moment
yeah my moment crazy song man yeah that
was the question that was 10 years ago
yeah [__] man time flies I'm old as [__]
yeah that was my moment was on there we
had a lot of we had some gems on there
yeah for you though like it's crazy
because with all your success right you
have like
you see a guy like DJ Khaled who's put
out like these gigantic anthems
meanwhile you have like you have gems
you got like dope records like you got
plaques as a DJ but you also as to her
like maybe we the best didn't
necessarily work out too crazy on the
artist side you got generation now which
is like
man [__] kudos to you guys um
why do you think like you never really
reached the heights as a solo DJ in
because there was a point in time where
you wanted Atlantic and then you ended
up at Koch right and you had some really
one by then or E1 but you had some like
really big records that maybe just
weren't like
I feel like we're slept on or didn't
like pop in the way that maybe I thought
they should have like why do you think
that is
um
I don't know that's a good question I
mean are you saying in comparison to
calendar just in my own just in in your
like like I feel like you had records
that could have been [__] number one
records yeah you know I mean I you know
I definitely had some records that
chartered that did amazing for me My
Moment was one of them wishing was
another one that was a big record yeah
it was hard you know I mean at at that
space or point in my career you know I'm
kind of like in comparison like
I'm more of a reserve type of person
like obviously Khalid is a very he's a
personality he's a very big personality
Superstar personality you know what I'm
saying and that and that that took him
to like amazing Heights and you know I
tip my hat off to them kudos to like all
his success but you know like for me
like there was just
my my route and you know how I attacked
the game was a little it was it was over
here you know but but I think that was
dope about it is that you know there's a
there's like obviously
there's room and there's space for both
of us to be these d dominant figures and
like go-to people that and can Inspire
other DJs 100 you know want to be the
next Cali or drink yeah you guys are
like the the bar for sure you know and
like for me it was like you know even
outside of just my records it was like
all right I'm still putting out tapes
that are classics through those years
like whether it was Fab or whether it
was oh the Fab [__] was so good Dream
Chasers you know I got Childish Gambino
tape like Jeremiah tape like you know I
was even even during that time you know
I did little babies tape like you know I
got some [__] so there was a lot about
the Childish Gambino [__] there was a
lot of [__] that I was I was doing I was
you know building Mean Street Studios
which became like a hub for you know
everything that was going on in the
culture in Atlanta when we were doing
with generation now like cultivating
uzi's career and Jack's career like you
know I just I wore a lot of hats so
you know for me it was like this is my
Lane you know I'm not trying to be
anybody else you know what I'm saying
like this is DJ Drama and this is how I
approach and attack the game and you
know what I mean it was like Hey I'm
gonna go for what's mine you know and
I'm gonna make a name for myself and and
be you know the greatest and you know go
down in history is arguably one of if
not the greatest DJ of all time yeah
yeah for sure
um for you
obviously a guy like Uzi is you know if
he's on the show he's headlining the
[__] roll him out he's he's he is
having a moment yeah again for sure over
and over he has these moments where it's
like no uzi's [__] a superstar
Rockstar for real for real
um you guys had kind of gotten to like a
weird patch in your relationship which
I'm sure happens a lot when artists sign
and like I I sympathize with kind of the
label side because it's like you know
you put all these resources behind a guy
you kind of put it put all the chips
onto somebody and once they pop you know
they start to be like well you know what
the [__] you guys seem to have gotten
over whatever weird hump you had because
I see pictures you guys together what's
your guys's relationship now it's great
um until we got over the hump you know
we're back in a in a a great working
space and a great personal space
um him and Canon have been working you
know very very hard on the pink tape I'm
looking forward to that and you know
like it like it's family's bicker you
know what I'm saying and like you said
like you know sometimes it plays out in
the public sometimes it doesn't and you
know like for us you know obviously
again like you said we've put so much
time and invested so much and like you
know his successes our success so even
at a space and time where we may differ
or you know I don't agree or have
another opinion on it it's like it's
it's a rock in our place because it's
like you know the bigger he is the
better it is for you absolutely so you
know it's kind of like you just gotta
you know roll with the punches and and
you know
keep putting that work in you know
obviously for us a great thing that
happened too when we were getting a lot
of the the uh brunt of the you know bad
publicity or bad press like with the Roc
Nation situation and all that [__] it
was like
Jack Harlow came and was like okay these
guys really know what they're doing like
shout out to steady Hendricks too you
know what I'm saying so you know and
we've we've been quite successful and
you know what I mean um and and honestly
like I've been in the game so long and
it's like I've weathered so many storms
so even with diverse [__] it's like you
know I'm
you you you hope and you you know
foresee like yo we'll get past this what
was like the Catalyst to you guys kind
of repairing the relationship
um time yeah yeah time it was you know
just coming you know coming back and you
know I guess just like
after a couple years of of
things kind of like letting it play out
it just you know we got back in a good
space and again you know we were we were
moving and grooving like generation now
like
you see this guy right here Jack Harlow
we got some things going I never
understood the Rock Nation thing because
I always like thought to myself like
it's not like you Lake and Don Cannon
aren't of the culture
who the [__] you are say it again so I
was like yo say it again why aren't why
is it Rock Nation to try to pull people
out of deals from like actual culture
vultures say it again DJ Drama like like
you try to [__] pull my guy out of
like like he's like he found this kid
you know what I'm saying like DJ Drama
did not pay bootleg Kev to make such an
accurate statement now as soon as that
happened I was like
there's people who you should Advocate
to get out of deals say it again but
we're talking about Don Cannon drama and
Lake come on bro like
three young black successful
men who met in college at the ages of 18
and 19
hbcus by the way and made a name for
themselves within the hip-hop culture
for two decades Paving the way and
putting on and providing for the culture
like huh yeah of anybody that should
have been embraced or it should have the
the way it played out that like I didn't
see them advocating to like get a Meek
Mill released off at Atlantic after he
complained about how he didn't like his
deal right
this [__] that was an adult anyway shout
out to Uzi he's a [__] Legend
absolutely how's the pink tape sounding
it's dope yeah yeah it's a lot of songs
I know they're trying to you know get
them down to a like a good solid
nah I don't want to say a number but
um they got a lot of music they got a
lot of music so you uh making this
Proclamation that just went to rock is
the New Philly Anthem I think only would
have actually worked out if you guys won
the Super Bowl it [__] me up when we
lost it [__] me up because I booked
you that night I was like we got drama
we about to have the eagle celebration
party let's go [__] it oh man [__]
Patrick Mahomes and his boy that I put
my foot in my mouth on that one but
everybody keeps leaving out I said this
year like I said this year but
um yeah that that was a viral moment
yeah uh that was fun what did you see in
like first of all how did you actually
find Jack Harlow because all these like
old videos of him being 12 and rapping
like went viral like like a year or two
ago and it was just so funny oh this
little [__] was rapping when he
was a child yeah how did you like
actually like discover a kid a little
white dude by all means kind of a little
nerdy dude dude in in Louisville so I
had a homeboy come to the studio one day
and just say his name to me
and I went on Instagram and just like
immediately followed them
and Jack saw me follow him and he like
followed me back and he wound up later
telling me like he told his homeboy like
yo DJ Drama just followed me like Damn
signed a drum and there's a very
legendary engineer that we've worked
with
um throughout my career who's uh mixed a
bunch of my records as well as a lot of
Classics including Dreams and Nightmares
worked with Waka worked with um Two
Chains his name is ky ky engineering so
yeah he has you know KY engineering he's
got a great tag yeah so his name is ky
because he's from Kentucky and
um around the same time that I had found
out about Jack he was also uh working
with Jack and he told Lake like yo I got
something I want to bring to you you
know I just want to get it to a certain
space so he was you know he was putting
a bug in Lake's ear about Jack so it
kind of like literally happened around
the same time and then Jack just one and
one day found his way to main streets
and then you know I heard he was in the
building and we like we met and we sat
down and we chopped it up we talked
music and life and movies and [__] like
that and you know I was I was just
impressed and then you know we came to
the table like you know we had a meeting
and uh all parties you know came to the
agreement that we want to design them
it's crazy too because I do feel like
you guys have kind of gone the old
school route of like actually developing
artists yeah that's how we like to do it
we like to get
involved like in the early stage of
their career like you know be part of
artist development yeah nobody's doing
that like like I remember like Jack was
just on Like These Little Indie tours
dropping shot dark night when we signed
them so it's kind of crazy like yeah in
an era where everybody's signing
[__] because it's it's viral you
guys have kind of taken the opposite
approach and reek the benefits I mean
it's it's paid off like we have you know
we have generational artists like we
have [__] Superstars you know what
I'm saying so you know like we were
talking it's it's quality over quantity
you know and and then there are times
when to be honest with within us
ourselves as a label like
we we discuss and like analyze like
about signing more you know more more
quantity than we we might do at the
level we are now so
um but you know when we when we signed
something like we really believe in it
and you know we we put that time in and
our artists are like you know artists
that are gonna be here you know what I'm
saying did you guys ever try to sign
estg
um we did and so that so you guys are
part of that whole was it like a bidding
war or no the to be honest
um Lake and um one of our anar's Royce
Monroe uh Royce was
was
um pretty much uh engineering estg he
did a lot of his early stuff at mean
streets and he was he was in the
building like all the time the entire
time and
um Lake also wanted to sign EST to the
label the way we were trying to go
around to structure the deal
um
wasn't exactly what estg was looking for
at the time
and the way not Nigel shot the Nigel you
know Nodge was who was uh a r at
Atlantic at a time you know used to be a
mean streets all the time he came to
Mean Streets met G and went and took him
to Gotti so that's how it happened yeah
and then there's like the legendary
video of yoga yeah I feel like anytime
you sign with CMG you just get a pile of
cash yeah like a big ass chain and cash
and all that so you know I mean
everything happens for a reason you know
um I can't front like G is definitely
somebody that like for me I'm like damn
we I wish
for sure does anybody else who was like
kind of like at the finish line but just
didn't for whatever reason ended up
working out they made a choice to go
somewhere else or
um yeah there's people there's there's
there's various people like you know uh
early on we were we were interested in
signing Tory Lanez
um
who else was there you know we were I
was
I was there early on in Amigo's career
um O.T genasis
OT yeah yeah we wanted to sign OT
um
yeah Amigos T Fly yeah we talked we won
the sign to fly you know what you guys
we won the sign problem
you guys you guys had scheme we asking
yeah yeah it's game still Generation Now
shout out to my guy scheme the Duke man
was it scheme are first yeah it's the
first person we ever signed let's go
scheme yep
scheme
are you guys actively always trying to
sign artists because now you have you do
have a roster of artists that you are
develop I mean there's a guy like said
Hendrix who's just been kind of just
putting in that grind and just
continuously staying consistent leveling
up slowly you know what I'm saying
putting out Quality Music Sunny digital
Sunny digital I didn't know Sunny
digital was yeah Sunny digital
generation now
um he has a project coming out we have a
female artist carvina
um that we've been developing uh she's
super fire and then we have some we have
some new artists you guys got to grab
someone from LA
yeah
I'm from Detroit
and Detroit I feel like Detroit's you
got to get somebody from Detroit bruh
yeah I'm open listen
it hit my line don't let y'all sign baby
Tron away from Ghazi hit my line and we
um we have um we're we're in the process
of uh rebooting the management company
on generation now too so we got some
some dope uh some some dope people on
the roster too that we're gonna announce
soon let will tell it from Taylor Gang
Uzi was almost tailor gang if you let
will tell it yeah how does he tell it he
just said we almost had Uzi I think it
was like it would have been like a
generation now Taylor Gang thing I don't
know was that ever like close to
actually happening because you guys
you're on every [__] Wiz Khalifa tour
that ever happens yeah so that's a
family thing shout out to shout out to
Will and Nate and the guys and all those
guys was that ever like a thing that was
close to it was it was a family
situation I mean basically you know
first time I ever heard Uzi by the way
was in Ty Dolla signs dressing or hotel
room in Boston like [__] I don't know
how many years ago he was just playing
his [__] on sound oh what the [__] is
this Ty was yeah yeah so vert you know I
took vert on tour with me during every
summer I go on tour with
he came out because I actually met him
during our first tour together we we did
um in 2014 one that one that I did with
Wiz and then the next year uh we went
out with uh whiz and Fall Out Boy and I
brought vert on the road with me so he
would come out on my set and perform
what you want and you know him and him
and uh wiz just you know established a
relationship in a bond and you know we
just put him on a record very early on
um and you know like so
in that sense like you know he was
family he was he was like he was like
teller gang you know but it wasn't like
a it wasn't like a paperwork situation I
think he might have had a Taylor Game
Changer he did so what happened was I
think at
um the first very Oozy Christmas we did
in Philly
um whiz gave him a teller gang chain on
the stage now mind you this is this is
still very early on when people one
didn't even know Uzi was signed to DJ
Drama Don Cannon let alone know what
generation now was so that literally was
kind of like the way that the name
generation now even got some traction
because it came out like
Uzi vert signs to Taylor Gang right you
know of course those are our brothers
does family but we were like uh this is
not exactly not the whole story yeah he
signed a generation now so then it
turned into like wait what's generation
now so it kind of like in a sense kind
of worked out in our favor because it
was a way for us to start to Brand
generation now listen do you want to win
some money gotta stop the interview but
listen there's so many opportunities to
gamble to bet on your favorite sports to
make Sports more interesting NFL season
is over but it's all good because the
opportunities to win are just getting
started yeah look there's so many things
you can do we're talking about NCAA NBA
NHL UFC boxing there's Blackjack
tournaments so much money to get in on
and check this out y'all if you sign up
right now using the promo code bootleg
do it right now you can get a welcome
bonus up to a thousand dollars plus
you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contact s
entry that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put in a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid is going
to win it Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas take me back you guys
get hit by the feds for
essentially the the mixtape hustle yeah
for people who don't know back in the
day I don't even know how many CD
burners you guys had to have had
but I know that you have been the name
bootless no I only had one of the ten
the ten ones yeah so you put the one at
the top and then you do ten at a time
and then had a little shitty printer I
was printing [__] mixtape covers out
on I would go to the [__] Staples and
buy the jewel cases I'd steal ink from
the [__] demo printers what a time
but you know how much money you think I
made you oh you made me a lot of money
you helped feed my baby oh I would say
you you DJ Smalls the game and G-Unit
radios
that was that was I mean because
Southern Smoke was like a big brand to
it very very big brand very big that was
my main competitor yeah it was like
gangster girls in Southern Smoke yep
yeah but but like do you know like what
the like was there like a certain thing
that happened that turned the fed's
attention to what was happening with
mixtape culture because technically
technically it was against the law I
guess yeah it was it was against the law
like what was the Catalyst I guess that
turned
I mean there's a lot of different
conspiracy theories I mean if if we if
we go back in in time like if we look at
where music was at that time like the
music business was
in a decline for sure so a lot of like
the bottom line wasn't
what they the heads or you know the top
of the food chains were used to seeing
and mixtapes were it was like the Wawa
West in a lot of ways it was such it was
it was like the crypto market so outside
of like the sanction gangster girls that
I was doing and the other like G-Unit
radios there were like all these just
random mixtapes out of people getting
songs and leaking them and taking them
from gmails and you know literally being
bootlegs so I think in a way it was
affecting
um potentially it could have been
affecting some of the business or maybe
they were just looking at mixtapes as a
scapegoat you know and then you know at
the same time mixtape started to show up
in like Best Buy and Target which I
never understood yeah she was like [__]
those are [__] bootlegs like
literally like they had barcodes on them
and that that wasn't coming for me you
know what I mean like so they didn't run
up in Best Buy with the M16s and arrest
them for bootleg in a racketeering but I
think when when that started to happen
and like you know me being the the go-to
guy like the top of the food chain it
was like you know maybe they were out to
send a message and and obviously it got
across because [__] changed after that
for sure so at the time in your Peak you
guys have your headquarters are you guys
burning the CDs Distributing the
mixtapes to like the bodegas the mixed
units of the world these websites where
you can go get mixtapes were you guys
the source of just your gangster girl
[__] or were you guys also producing
other people's shoes nah we were just
doing all in-house stuff so it was all
Affiliates all Affiliates yeah so
everything that we were doing was
strictly like under our uh there are
brand
um so there were gangster girls but like
that was one of the problems too like so
when when when they went to
gangstergirls.com
one of the red flags that they saw
wasn't necessarily the gangster grills
it was the other CDs that had like
Michael Jackson on the cover yeah or
Beyonce on the cover yeah and it was
like a blend of Michael Jackson so
mashup [__] yeah where there was like
the radio mixes yeah they seen [__] like
that and like oh these are like you know
there's Michael Jackson and what were
you guys selling mixtapes per piece for
back then like let's say if someone
bought it directly from you maybe like
two three dollars oh wow I used to do I
think five bucks a pop or five for 20.
for wholesale no no just like at the
swap meet in my space Oh I'm talking
about Jose Jose I was doing like 250
yeah like 253 dollars
um a piece probably like
seven eight dollars or something like
that I don't I don't remember everything
I was doing at that time was in bulk so
we were it was all wholesale [__] yeah
it was at a lesser price people were
buying like
quantities of from 200 to a thousand at
the time like non-stop in a hypothetical
World in which you were doing that but
you're not who you are right now what
would have been the best year that you
made mixtape money-wise in a
hypothetical world where it actually
didn't happen
and far Universe far away
are you so let me get this question
straight I'm not I'm asking you if you
were someone who looks just like you in
a different Universe how much illegal
mixtape money would somebody like you
have made at a peak without it actually
being you
know what's crazy to answer that like
and then hypothetical World somebody who
may have looked like me like in like
another Universe doppelganger like a
hundred thousand a month wow yeah and
that is that taxable
hypothetical world where this person
some of it is yeah I was it was a a
hypothetical person would have been
paying taxes on it because it was gone
through the banking system it was Cash
involved as well yeah but what's crazy
is even after the raid like during the
like that pith era and live mixtape era
yo I probably made more money than how
because they were they were cutting me
checks
to make whatever gangster girls I put
out exclusive to their site so when an
artist would come to me to do a tape I'd
be like that's fine but it has to go on
that Biff and then that pif was what was
the Gap hip check for like for
dedication what was the check probably
like 50. jeez they would give me they
gave me 50 and gave Wayne a buck 50.
like and yo when you guys would drop
those [__] tapes like [__] like that
people get shut the [__] with crash like
I I made more money after the raid off
mixtapes than I made during the earlier
days I bought uh the first time I ever
interviewed you or met you I was like a
nobody intern at Power in Phoenix and I
had to I bought the white tea which I'll
never forget DJ Drama [__] off a mixed
unit and I was like man I'm about to be
drunk I'm about to bust out the tea that
was and and we did that interview like
during my first album run right after
the raid so that was like oh seven yeah
it was around it was it was early bro I
was like a nobody yeah but I never
forget like I remember you from that
time I was like a skinny the first time
we met in in Phoenix when we did that
[__] triple XL DJ Drama tea yeah
shout out to mix unit man I used to buy
a hell of shirts off of there yeah they
had everything yeah [__] amen I just
saw well I guess DatPiff isn't actually
a closing they put up a tweet that said
that they're reading I saw that I was so
sad that's crazy I mean it's crazy
because Fab dm'd it to me too like I had
I think I I saw it on
um I saw a post about it and then right
after I saw a post about it Fab dm'd it
to me and I think he dm'd it to me
because I we just recently sat down for
um something I got coming out and we
were talking about that era but like
just to think about that like imagine if
DatPiff does or did had gone under like
that's like a generation yeah it's like
it's like a part of our culture that
could potentially go like lost you know
what I mean like so much of that stuff
is not available on the dsps and like
you know where people don't know where
to find it and like if we lose if we
lose that you know that time or and that
music from that that era it's like
it'll just be like a word it'll be like
damn do you remember or you know it'll
it'll just be spoken about so it's
really it's like really important that
we we get a hold of that you know just
just to keep it alive
got to keep the history where else am I
gonna go I don't want to go listen to
some shitty YouTube [__] [__] to go
listen to like the Pharrell tape or some
little brother
and one of my goals is something I've
been working on too is definitely
bringing some of the classics to the
dsps like so they they uh can be
available so people you know there's so
many projects like and it's a lot of
work but it can be done like it can be
done so
um one that we're definitely in the
process of working on is is getting
dedication to up on dsps it's really
just what clearing the Beats yeah
clearing the pub clearing the Beats like
you know I'm sure Wayne's down of course
yeah yeah yeah that can't do it without
without the gun can't do it without him
um who all do you have on this new album
um
I got a lot of great people Tyler the
Creator who's okay who's the town who's
on the Tyler song Tyler and I just just
wait this way give me something here
just wait there you may wait long enough
for this [__] interview
it's Tyler and you can't put Tyler on a
song with anybody so it's just Tyler
yeah so he's got track number two or the
intro or what is it it's I mean it feels
like what a way to start track two what
what a way to you know what a way to
come off a Grammy what track number is
it what a way to start so it's the intro
I love it thank you
um Jack Harlow's on the album I sure
would hope so a little Uzi vert
uh Lil Wayne's on the album Jesus uh 42
dogs on album
um the Russell's on the album lovely
Russell uh side hives on the album
is on the album uh money bag Yo's on the
album Gucci's on the album Jeezy's on
the album nipsy hustles on the album
Nipsey
blast is on the album did you put Nipsey
and blast on a song together
um I got some [__] on there
I got some [__] you're telling me you
got nipsy and blast on the album
together I got some [__] I'm pretty
excited for you to hear it
how do you get the nipsy verse
um you know Nipsey did a lot of
recording at uh Mean Street yeah
yeah
so you so you okay lost the archives so
we got this old nipsy verse you reach
out to Black Sam make sure obviously you
have to clear with the family of course
yeah and then and then a lot of that
process and then you send the verse to
blast and say I need a hook
yeah
yeah you know how it goes you know how
to put songs together blasting Nipsey
man
featuring another artist
from L.A no no no
wow yeah I can't wait it sounds like a
symbols on the album December is Simba
in The wrestle on a song together no no
I love it shout out to the Bay man yeah
whiz is on there tip is on there so I I
feel like I have some of the
um
you know the the uh
the people you would expect to see work
with drama as well as a lot of like new
voices as well so it's a good you know
combination yo how do you kind of look
back at the Grand Hustle era of your
career because when you were on Grand
Hustle it was like the hottest [__]
moving yeah like I think a lot of things
probably you know kind of went wrong or
you know I mean obviously Bob is a star
I think Trader truth is on Grand Hustle
am I driven tip had a hell of a roster
if we really want to put it into
perspective young bro I actually really
like the guy that snitched Alpha Mega
yeah you like dopamega he was hard as
[__] but but you know he was kind of
like the first six nine
he was an early teller because he was a
fire he was on that road bro he was on
that record with Busta Rhymes yeah we
had to perform that without tip at the
hip-hop Awards when tip got was that
called hurt yeah it hurt oh yeah his
voice was crazy yeah we performed that
just somebody just recently sent me that
YouTube video it was like why clef
opened up and then we and then me
[__] Alpha Mega and Buster performed
hurt without tip because he was
incarcerated people were hit just got
locked up like literally that day do you
think him getting locked up like kind of
affected like the trajectory of the
label as a whole in a sense I mean you
know because he had Meek Mill was
originally ground hustle and I didn't
know that yeah Meek was over a groundhog
I think I did not for a period of time
you know I mean you know Travis Scott
was I remember Travis Travis was Grand
Hustle yeah
um B.o.B Iggy Azalea
um oh man you know tip has had a his
hand in the in in a nice you know uh
I don't think he gets the credit that he
should deserve when it comes to like
having a knife for talent I agree TI is
an amazing guy for talent yeah yeah and
then you know there's others that he
like he talks about you know Savage and
Thug coming to him wanting to sign and
you know him telling him look like I
think you should do it this way I could
give you this million dollars but you
know just I could give you this game
that'll go a lot farther so
yeah but but as far as like that time in
my career I I don't know if what I want
to call it like a golden era but it was
a hell of a it was a hell of a time like
you know being TI's DJ when T.I was like
the hottest rapper like he was literally
the hottest rapper out like you know we
was we was doing tours across the state
I went around we went around the world
together
um he was doing [__] Chevy
commercials he was like I was in ATL
like you know he he had the number one
album and number one movie out at the
same time like you know it was on fire I
mean literally I got to go on tour with
Jay-Z because of tip
um and then you know my brand gangster
girls was the hottest thing going so
like you know to be DJ Drama and and
what T.I was and for us to you know be
together at that time it was like it was
kind of what I had always
I dreamed for in a way of like a DJ
artist relationship like growing up
looking at you know Run DMC and Jam
Master Jay and fresh prince and Jazzy
Jeff or being Rakim or even like cool
kid at 50 or like yeah you guys were
like synonymous with each other for a
minute yeah like green and M early on
like when when I when I when tip was
like rising and like I was doing my
thing and I was like oh yeah like this
is this could be my guy you know what
I'm saying so you know I like I used to
literally go to the studio to the
groundhog Studios which later became my
Studios but I would literally go there
like every day just to be around just to
kind of like Vie for that DJ Gig because
I knew what that's coming what that
could be yeah
and then we had some hell of a times on
the road like I saw a lot of a lot of a
lot of things what was the Jay-Z tour so
originally it was the best of both
worlds tour and the one that like went
left the incident happened in New York
and during the New York show
Jay was bringing out a bunch of people
one and then that was when tip had bring
him out out so he brought tip out for
that show so after that show it became
basically the jay-zm Friends tour so we
wound up on the tour so for the next
like month you know I was on the road
watching [__]
Jay-Z DMX Mary J Blige perform every
night you know like it was crazy it was
insane like you know this is like 0-4 it
was all it was insane oh four who was it
who was Jay's DJ at that time was it
Neil Armstrong
um Jay didn't have
a DJ if I'm not mistaken they were
running the board just running the the
the the
um the instant replay from the okay from
the side
yeah speaking of shout out to Green
Lantern and a legend Greenland Jay-Z's
DJ Eminem's DJ Nazis DJ like who can say
that I tell them that all the time one
of my personal favorite mixtape creators
of all time oh yeah he's like those
Green Lantern remixes oh there's no
gangster girls if there's no Green
Lantern Green Lantern is a fight like we
used to like salivate pause over Green's
tapes like we was when green would drop
we would sit there and just like the rap
phenomenon [__] we would be so
overwhelmed and just so like yo we gotta
get on our [__] like you know Green was
green was our green was our Idol bro
like even before I knew him like you
know and and now like he's such a great
personal friend of mine but like coming
up like Green Lantern was the epitome of
what I wanted to be as a mixtape DJ
shout out to Green
um there's a list of artists who never
did a gangsta grills
who's the one person who you never got
to do a tape with but it almost happened
it was like almost there but it just for
whatever reason didn't end up working
out
um there's a couple
uh Drake
um black thought oh
which still better man make that [__]
happen for you feeling which still needs
to happen
um
Travis Scott
Nicki Minaj
um
who am I forgetting like
who's she forgetting like
Travis Travis Nikki Drake Black Thought
black thought
big there's another big one I think
I mean that's a hell of a lot any of
those that you you started to work on it
but it just didn't get finished or just
never got out well we started the work
on the Drake and Gucci tape
collaboration
um there were like there are a couple
songs that got started for that
um that will never probably hear no they
came out oh they did yeah they came out
on like the cold Wars
and then the tape that's that is beam me
up Scotty was originally supposed to be
against the girls so the Nicki Minaj
tape that you know that just holiday
dinner right yeah holiday and I think
trapaholics or something so yeah but
that was originally a gangster girls the
gangster grills drop
I just saw somebody was getting sued
for
using someone's voice as a drop on all
these records
did you ever have to like get any sort
of legal paperwork to clear the drop
bro Little John is the
like greatest human being
on the planet like he is to this day and
like by me saying this I'm not it's not
even like there's a worry because
if he had any intentions at like he
could have came so long ago you know
what I'm saying like I've literally been
running with his voice for 22 years like
since he was the first host of gangster
grills like my brand has has been built
off of his back you know I'm saying and
he's done nothing but show love like you
know so was that the original drop was
from the original Gangsta Grill so he
came the first time I ever had a host
for Gangster girls was John
um and he came and hosted the tape and
he was just doing drops and in the drop
he said Gangsta Grizzlies yeah and then
the next tape I did I didn't have a host
so I was like all right well [__] it
I'ma just you run his voice back and
just like keep playing it and that was
how it was born and then it was over
from there shit's legendary crazy so
legendary you know for you now that Jack
is kind of crossed over to Superstar
status I know he's got a movie coming
soon just did his first uh headlining
Arena tour yeah uh just got nominated
for best rap album of the Year even
though I don't think he should have got
nominated
personally but yeah I love the guy
um have you guys because I do feel like
when an artist hits that wave where
they're just like [__] out of here
do you guys keep your relationships as
solid as it always has been
I mean Jack is a solid human being so
because he kind of got to witness I kind
of feel like he was somehow like weirdly
wedged in between like the uzi
Generation Now thing yeah he was it it
was kind of unfair for him yeah you know
but like he kind of got to see and what
was dope is that he really you know he's
like
I feel like him
really standing by me during that meant
a lot you know what I'm saying and at a
time when like he could have just kind
of like
I don't I don't want to say stay out of
it in a sense of that he was in it but
when the
the press or the way it was being
portrayed as if we were bad guys jack
really went out on a limb and put his
arm around me and was like yo this is my
guy you know what I'm saying and I
always tip my hat off to him for that
you know what I'm saying for because he
didn't have to do that he could have he
could have totally stayed out of the way
you know I don't even know if you
remember like there were some pictures
and then like you know like Emma Uzi had
a little back and forth in between there
I think I remember that they had never
even met you know what I'm saying it was
it was basically just because I was in
the middle but
um so yeah to your point I mean he did
get to see that and you know obviously
when when when you have artists like you
know you have these conversations early
on in their careers like yo you you know
you when you're a superstar like you
know people change or things happen and
you know Jack's just he's a solid guy
you know obviously at 25 you know where
he is with the type of success and this
and the stardom he's not the same kid he
was at 19 but you know he's he's a very
focused individual like you know he made
the decision years ago to to stop
drinking like you know to like
get in a workout regimen like he was
really really focused and you know I
just I just think outside of rap music
like
he's solid you know what I'm saying so
you know
they're they're all artists you know and
and
in our own ways me included like there's
always a certain level of narcissism I
feel like that comes along with being an
artist so you know there's times when
you you watch people being there be in
their mode their mode and you know it
comes with the territory you know it's
not something I'm like I'm I've been
doing this too long so I get it but um
but somebody like Jack I will say you
know I've watched I've watched his
growth and you know I'm proud that like
he still has maintained this this level
of of humility has he started working on
a new album yet yes
because I know I mean I feel like he had
such a wild year yeah like I kind of
feel like if I'm like Jack Harlow I'm
unplugging for like yeah a cool 90 days
for sure before the movie the album
first class I mean because he's he was
ever it was Jack Harlow season like he
was everywhere like you couldn't look
left or right without seeing Jack Harlow
so I would I mean to your point like
I would say these last couple months
she's it's been a little more quiet
right outside of maybe like a Super Bowl
commercial or he wasn't even in Arizona
for the Super Bowl he was not
he was he wasn't there because I was
like I was like oh I already know he's
about to do all the white clubs he
didn't go to Arizona for the Super Bowl
he wasn't an All-Star you know nobody
wants to go to Utah he was he was quiet
for the Grammys outside of going to the
Grammys right you know he's been in a
real work mode
um for the most part so you know he's
he's back in Louisville
um
work and and a space in an environment
that he's comfortable in and you know
he's he's got a lot of new music
um
give me the NBA young boy tape did you
have to go to Salt Lake City to link
with him or were you just sending over
[__] after like how's that because he's
kind of like a you know truthfully yeah
truthfully I got a call
on Tuesday or Wednesday
yo
I'm dropping a mixtape
Miss NBA young boy calling you I want
you to host it
yo I got like two other tapes coming out
bro but
the week of
the week of oh wow he was trying to get
out of that deal
he called me Tuesday or Wednesday I
think I did the tape if I if you call me
twos would we dropped the tape Thursday
night I probably finished it Thursday
and we dropped it but like I'm not
saying no to an NBA of course and it's
just like you know it was like I had
already the the Jeezy and the Snoop and
I and people that knew knew about him
right so I was like oh my god when I
come with a NBA young boy tape I'm gonna
[__] these [__] up like they're on one
day they're gonna be like yo drums on
some other drums it was like we were no
we was in New York I called you I called
you you did and I was like am I [__]
crazy or are you dropping three mixtapes
today I was like what the [__] is going
on
this [__] is crazy you just got a Grammy
bro chill let these [__]
breathe a little bit no chill not
letting nobody and it was Snoop Jeezy
and NBA young boy yeah that was crazy
Jesus Christ listen man I mean let's put
it in a perspective like
I've been what I've been DJing 30 years
I've been in the business 20 years two
decades plus like I've had a moment or
moments where I was on fire so now in
2021 22 23 I'm back on fire like you
can't turn it up yeah you got to like
you can't take that [__] for granted and
mind you even the years before that like
it's not like I haven't been working
it's not right even Jack hasn't been
successful Uzi it wasn't doing this
thing or I didn't have my Vegas
residency or I was dropping things here
or there like it's not like I have I I
haven't been busy but to be in this
space right now at 45 with my skin
glowing like this yeah drinking a gallon
of water looking 21 like come on man I'm
not not playing you have never stopped
doing clubs never
and you're in a position where you don't
need to do nightclubs I don't so why do
you still do the club [__]
um
I don't like to leave any money on the
table
and
I'll it keeps me it keeps me fresh like
I like
I like to know like I like to as a DJ I
like to still feel like I know what's
going on you know like you still have
the fingers on the like pulse of the
shoes yeah because you kind of have to
have that in order to rock clubs
absolutely like you you have to it like
forces you to be yeah if you're not if
you're not in the clubs regularly or
know what's going on like yeah you can't
just go and not to the type of clubs
that we do or that I'm in like I'm
respectfully I'm not DJing for 45 year
olds like right I'm djm for uh the club
age which is what like 21 to 30 right
something or whatever so you know to do
that you know you gotta you gotta stay
in the mix and it's crazy because I did
get to a point like when I was like
30 37 38 like I came to Lake and I was
like bro like when I'm when I turned 40
bro I don't want to do clubs anymore
like I don't want to be that guy like I
don't want to be the old head in the
club and so there was a there was a
small period a small window where like
Lake wasn't booking me as much you know
what I mean like and we had
a bunch of other revenues of of you know
revenue streams coming in but I wasn't
really doing a lot outside of maybe like
my Vegas residency or um big [__] yeah
but I was because you'll do like you'll
pull up and do I mean we were talking
about flux rip to flux in San Diego but
I mean you know I mean most of the [__]
I do is pretty you know it's it's of a
certain caliber for sure but
again like
you you know just to be in this position
and to get these opportunities like you
know it's a blessing like
the moment you take it for granted bro
the mo is the moment they take it away
from you you know what I mean like
because you got to get it while you're
getting it because you don't know how
long it's Gonna Last and that's what I'm
saying like and I've it I've had a
blessed career that it's lasted this
long you know what I mean and like
you know but I I still feel Forever 21
like the store here it is you know
that's a bar like I see why you didn't
rap drama I'm [__] with you I said
that bar on the tape Forever 21 like
this Mr Thanksgiving God damn it what's
up guys hey shout out to our family at
uh blue chew man listen I know we always
are getting feedback about our Bluetooth
interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discreet package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be everywhere erection
should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just dropped
the mint chewable same active ingredient
as Levitra that's right so what you need
to do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsocksofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
Odd Socks Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview all
right we talked about the greatest DJ of
all time discussion I always you know
say that I in my opinion you are the
goat
um who are your favorite DJs let's go a
couple categories you're very vocal
about that too what's the like when you
say that like I just feel like there's a
point in time what's the reception that
you get when you say that even from
other DJs I'm curious I think I think a
lot of details I think because like you
like tweet that like yo drums the
greatest I mean what are we talking
about just I mean who's the other guy to
get a Grammy besides Jazzy Jeff right
Tyler has a Grammy does he yeah what
song uh the Nipsey record that's right
so me Khalid Jeff
I might be it when it comes to DJs the
Nipsey record was
wow yep shout out to Khaled yeah yeah
salute but who's your favorite Club DJ I
have two favorite I have two okay Mr
Rogers shout out to H-Town and DJ boof
shout out to boof boof just did um
but is he he's Nikki's DJ right yes he's
Nick he's DJ and Fabs and he was Fabs
yeah Super Bowl he hopped on when Fab
jumped on yeah boo for Mr Rogers are
like my like
I hate playing after them [__] like
they're cold bro I hate it like Mr like
Mr Rogers
he does a better DJ Drama set than I do
wow like one one year we were on tour
we were in Houston and I had an after
party and
this [__] just like was in the club
giving me my flowers
and like the drop the the DJ Drama yo me
and Lake was sit we were like how am I
supposed to go on now blown away like yo
this [__] just [__]
and then boof is another one like you
know I will I've I've seen booth on tour
when we just did the legends of the
streets tour and that had to be a crazy
Tour by the way it was a it was a dope
experience it was boozy on that one or
he he was on he was on the last show oh
yeah he was on One show and then it
didn't work out yeah
um but boof something happened where uh
I guess Fab had like maybe missed a
flight or something right and boof
literally had to hold it down for like
Fab's whole Performance Set and I think
it was like Valentine's day too and he
just like he's a problem like boof is a
problem so
um those two guys are my definitely
two current favorites like of I love
those names yeah yeah
um of course Jeff is you know Jeff is
amazing I remember seeing gem Master Jay
live one time it was incredible
yeah Jeff is special though I saw I I
when I was living in Vegas I remember
like when he would DJ I would always go
either go see her him or Z Trip just to
be like just to go see some ill DJ yeah
yeah yeah yeah Z Trip was dope there was
a time when Encore unplugged Jazzy Jeff
and it caused like chaos in the Vegas
nightclub club scene they like shut him
off because he was he wouldn't stop
playing hip-hop this was like the dark
EDM days of Vegas yeah and Encore
there's you know shacky Green yes so
shecky I think had booked him there
and you know he's an old school hip-hop
guy but like the GM at the club
like shut Jazzy Jeff off because he was
too hip-hop that's crazy like can you
imagine
cutting off
DJ Jazzy Jeff it's like let his he just
went silent yeah but bro Vegas used to
be [__] now I remember those times
weird I remember them trying to like go
DJ Crown nightclub or some [__] yeah did
you ever do a crown yeah I did Crown I
used to I did a bunch of I used to do
Chateau oh [__] you wear Chateau a lot
yeah I was that [__]
yeah I was at Paris it was in it was in
Paris yeah yeah and then what was the
club that Ray J used to be a part of do
you remember this was like oh 809.
poetry poetry I used to do poetry all
the time did you ever do strip hop I'd
of course strip Hoppers yeah we did
strip hop it's the first time I ever saw
a woman swallow an entire like animal
balloon she blew the whole [__] up it
was like the size of this table and it
just went away and she kept dancing and
I was like is her stomach actually gonna
pop the balloon and like is she gonna
die or like is she gonna yeah strip pop
was the time that was that was the old
time
um and then
um yeah boo from Rogers uh what about
let's what are yours
I don't know dude
all time
am's pretty [__] incredible too I
guess like for me probably I'm sorry and
and then I have to um
um
who am I what oh [__] who Am I who am I
not thinking of from I can't believe I I
just went blank from Canada
he was a DMC Champion oh eight-track a
track a track's a beast a track is a
problem hey track I love a track I love
he's he's see I like he might be my he
might be third for me well the reason I
like eight like guys like a track is
because I feel like a track you could
throw him in any situation any situation
any situation and he's gonna rock that
[__] any situation [__] ratchet party
EDM party doesn't matter he could go to
a [__] DMC anything's actually
probably my favorite DJ ever I bought
his DVD and [__] he's one of mine too
he's one of my favorite DJs ever like
all around like those are the kind of
DJs that I like I'm like yo if I could
throw if I could see somebody Rock
whatever
and they got whatever in their Arsenal
and you know to his credit too like he
had a very successful label yeah Fool's
Gold who's going you know he [__] was
Kanye's DJ like you know a track's name
needs to get he was a DMC Champion like
as a child as a [__] 13 year old
crazy you know like aatrax probably my
favorite personal favorite DJ great guy
Scratch DJ I really like DJ Babu from
the B junkies Babu was dope but yeah
some Club [__] bro I don't know dude
like I guess it depends on what club I'm
in because I'm so like current that I'm
like I just know if I see someone's name
on a flyer I'm like I know the music's
gonna be straight like if Dre Sinatra's
DJing I'm like cool I know it's gonna be
good of course if DJ bad is DJing I mean
I'm in La so I'm naming L.A guys yeah
I'm like I know it's going to be a good
time yeah you know what I mean Dre is
Dre is like I heard Sean Mack once oh
yeah Sean Max a great one too Sean Mack
Sean like going to Chicago he's another
one that I hated coming on after
um I love what about on the mixtape side
if we exclude clue because that's going
to be the easy one to name yeah but I
did want to again About Dre was was dope
About Dre too is like I feel like
like he's like a a Lou Will in a way
like you know what I'm saying like Dre
is he's a [__] bro he's clutch he's
clutch at all times like you know he
saved my ass twice during Super Bowl
weekend Meek Mill hops on and Trey's
just letting [__] fly while he's
performing and he throws on one of the
records that Meeks like on the second
verse of and goes and he looks at him
like you got my verse ready Andrea's
like
in the headphones and on the Fly Like
perfect timing and I just looked at Dre
like what record was it was it [__] you
oh yes
can you drop the record and meek almost
look at him like what the [__] you
playing this for yeah and Trey's like
and I was like dog thank you and then
even because your [__] wasn't working
with the controller we had at the club
yeah so Dre was like I got it it's all
good yeah we worked out of Drake's
computer and then you know me and Dre
like when I first started
working a lot in La
um it there was this club called Colony
on Monday nights so All-Star Weekend in
like 2010 was in LA and I think I had a
bunch of gigs and then I got added to do
Colony that Monday of All-Star and this
was like around the time when La was
kind of like changing you know what I'm
saying and then so like the the the type
of music that I was playing and like
coming from Atlanta like I did colony
and I [__] rocked and then
um me and Dre like established this
relationship so Dre would start that
that was really when the West Coast was
kind of resurging with the sound like
rack city like the early muster records
so Dre was putting me on to all the
California music and he was like yo play
this you'll play this and then I would
take it back home and like start putting
it on Shade 45 early on because I was
familiar with it so like you know he's
he we literally have been like rock for
a decade plus and I've been watching
those whatever happened you had a
short-lived DJ crew that was supposed to
kind of rival what the Heavy Hitters are
you talking about the Affiliates or like
the academy the academy
um so we we around
2012 2013 we wanted to Trey was a part
of it yeah Dre was a part of it amen we
had a bunch of people a part of it right
um
ah [__] uh diamond cuts Mr Rogers
um it was like 15. it was like
short-lived though right well what
happened to be honest was around the
time that we launched it
I was going into my a r
um job and then we started a generation
now
started
we went into the direction of you know
the label and so I think that a lot of
my you know bandwidth yeah our bandwidth
and just like our focus wasn't
necessarily on what we had set out to do
with the DJ crew at the time so it kind
of didn't it didn't become what it
became but you know like you know those
we're still proud of you know the the
Arsenal or the the the collective that
we put together and then there are
people that still represent or you know
right like still family
um but then you said something before
that I wanted to bring up was it about
you would said
in the club you you were about to name
somebody else
I was just saying that like if I go to a
club if I see someone's name on a flyer
I'm like there's just like a few names
and I'm like oh
you know like I love bad is dope
um yeah and then Sean Mac we see John
Max dope yeah I mean who else we've
talked about eight eight track
oh you said okay so taking away kalu you
said a mixtapes oh mixtapes yeah yeah so
if you take clue out the who's who's
your personal favorite mixtape DJs after
yourself obviously
because there's been there's some I mean
there's guys like Big Mike okay Jay
Smalls then there's who kid there's I
mean so of course I'm gonna say Canon
first
um and then I'm gonna go Green Lantern
who kid like Green Lantern or who kid
are
are why we are where we are like we we
would we would religiously
listen and cop greens tapes and who kids
tapes and and really for two different
reasons too like because totally
different styles of DJs two totally
different styles of DJing like green
skill wise creativity wise like actually
making records making records like you
know
the drops just you know sound wise
nobody could touch green and then who
kid for like marketing like like the the
way he was packaging his the mixtapes
like the fold outs yeah the sponsorships
like he it just was bigger than life
like I think he's the first person I've
ever seen like with a fold out like you
know where you get to see the energy it
was not just a piece of paper like it
would open it up and it'd be like all
this [__] on there and these you know
accolades and sponsorships and all this
[__] and was like next level [__] you
know and it was at a time when fifth was
the biggest thing in in rap music
um so I love who cared for for that and
his and his personality as well like
um you know it's just a [__] he's a
fool like for sure he's just a [__]
fool
um so yeah that would those would be my
go-to's
um am I leaving anybody out
hmm so we got a clue green light green
we got who kid
um
yeah I mean early on
you know I I I'd show some love to s s
and doo-wop for early on in my career
you know for being Inspirations
um you mentioned like not having
bandwidth to do a lot you still you you
still do A Shade 45 is it a Sunday
nights Friday Friday nights so you're
still I mean you're still you're still
doing a radio show are you still voice
in radio stations Imaging I still do
that you got the label you're putting
music out you're doing just a lot yeah
at what sacrifice
has what has been the biggest sacrifice
you've had to make in the last 20 years
because it could be time I mean you have
thrown like a grown daughter yeah you
know what I'm saying like is it time
with the kids absolutely family life
that was that was probably the the
biggest sacrifice was
um
uh was
father time like there was a lot of
times you know during my kids like
earlier obviously not so much these days
because they're older but you know that
I was gone a lot and I was on the road
like summer tours or just like on the
weekends so you know
um that time you can't get back I mean
you know it also benefited for them
because they live a very good life and
you know have a very good lifestyle but
um yeah I think that's probably the
biggest sacrifice that that you make
um
in this business what is some pointers
you can give in terms of time management
and just like things you've learned over
the years to where you're kind of like
making sure you're because time is the
most valuable
uh currency I think absolutely like like
you know you got so much [__] that
you're doing on a day-to-day basis like
you you know like what are the things
the practices you do because I got so
much [__] going on I'm trying to figure
out how to fit in all kinds of [__] bro
I'll be wearing myself thin you know
what I'm saying so like is there
anything that you've kind of figured out
over the years that like is helpful in
terms of productivity and being able to
kind of do so much I mean there's a lot
you know there's I mean first of all
like
self-preservation like you know eating
clean drinking a lot of water you know
getting sleep like those things working
out like those things definitely are
important in
truly anyone's line of work or at this
stage in life
um I could not have done it without the
people around me like you know like I
don't know if I would be here if it
wasn't for Lake you know what I'm saying
like when you know we've known each
other for 25 26 years but like when he
came into the picture
in a a business sense
um in my career like I think we really
we really meshed and you know we were
able to really like you know
um
create and put together some amazing
things like you know I just give them a
lot of credit when it comes to the
creative side when it comes to the
business side when it just comes to
intellect like he's he's literally
probably you know one of if not the
smartest people I know
um and besides him you know just in
general having a good team of people
around you having good people around you
in general you know what I'm saying is
very important like obviously I don't do
this by myself you know what I mean you
can't manage it all on your own you know
um so salute to the whole Generation Now
staff you know of course you know Canon
has always been very pivotal pivotal
pivotal is that the right word I don't
[__] know something pivotal pivotal
pivotal pivotal pivotal pivotal pivotal
Canon's been very pivotal
excuse me
um you know he's my he's my my right
hand like you know we've built the
empire together
um and then what else is there you know
definitely sometimes off
have you learned to say no to more [__]
you know I'm I'm I'm I'm a real
yes guy in a lot of ways like they're
because you're like I don't want to
leave no money on the table yeah but I
mean it definitely has to be the right
money like I'm not scrounging for a
dollar you know what I'm saying but um
you know I I think the key to a lot of
My Success is a yes in a way but and
when I say that I don't want to just say
that I'm just like out here just doing
whatever but like
a yes in a way of like people still find
it surprising like I might just meet a
person and they'll tell me they're
artists and I'm like here take my number
right and I'll give them my number and
like you know
I might not necessarily answer but you
know at the same time they send me
they'll send me [__] and I'll look at it
and the fact you're giving your number
out is crazy yeah I mean they're like yo
this is like like I've definitely done
you know that Lake definitely gets calls
like yo who is [__] who is so and so
who is Green Valley monster spa day like
what a [__] rap name I'm like yeah so
I don't know hey was there ever last
question before you get out of here was
there ever a tape that you said no to
because maybe the money wasn't right or
they weren't quite there yet that you
regretted later
thank you
uh
uh because the money wasn't right like
maybe somebody tried to get a gangster
girls from you but at that time maybe
they weren't maybe they weren't on your
radar and or they couldn't make the
business make sense but later on you
were like damn honestly the only only
one of that
like that for me
and people find this is very shocking
like Rick Ross does not have a gangster
girls
and like there was a period of time when
I think they're like Def Jam came to me
about doing a tape and there was a
number on the table and and and at the
time I wasn't handling my business but
they didn't want to pay for the tape and
so it didn't happen but honestly I would
have done a Rick Ross tape just on the
strength of yes it's Ross like okay he's
got classic mixtape a thousand percent
yeah like so I would have did that like
it's it's shocking to me to think that
Ross doesn't have like a gangster girls
like he's not part and and mind you like
that's my guy we've I've done records
for him you know he's done records for
me like we we've we've worked it's kind
of crazy we've worked a lot throughout
the years but we don't have a gangster
girls together so that's kind of
shocking is that something like now that
you're back in this bag
are you trying to seek out tapes where
you're like hey I know that like I'm hot
like the gangster girl's brand is as hot
as it's been in the last you know 10 15
years for sure
maybe I now know like approach Ross or
maybe I now approach there are there are
some people that I've like put kites out
to like yo but hey you know Now's the
Time Now's the Time for sure absolutely
but the majority of the time I'm getting
a lot of phone calls
um and good phone calls so it's like you
know like I got another one coming
that's crazy
man
yeah on the way yeah so it's done it's
done yeah it's done what state are they
from
what state oh yeah give it away I can't
oh oh in that case oh yeah I can't I
can't tell you it would give it away
it's not Georgia I can't tell you the
state it's definitely not Georgia it's
definitely not Tennessee it's definitely
not Florida it's definitely not
California yeah it's not
it'd give it away huh it would
be Louisiana
it would give it away it would and we
give it away
yeah it would give it it would it would
put it in the box of like you would
yeah you would figure it out it would
give it away yeah
okay I'll find out off camera because I
will guess this correctly on camera if
you give me a couple of it's not
Michigan
that means that they kind of have to be
like the face of where they're from and
there's not a lot of other [__] going on
from where this person's from even when
I even if I were to tell you it would
still take you a second but then you
would figure it out but or let's put it
like this if I was to say it they would
figure it out
you're never gonna get it so
you might as well just ask another
question well you're definitely not
doing you're not doing one with tech N9
are you for [__] Kansas City I don't
know hmm
oh
[Music]
we're kind of getting into the region I
see huh we're getting into the region
are we let's see
I don't think you have any hints around
here hmm
okay
well
let me get a list of the 50 states and
I'm gonna give you one guess outside of
that one uh Fabio
um Pusha T oh okay yeah what's up with
the push of t-shirt yeah I just got into
a [__] serious argument with Jim
Jones on video about
them saying that Pusha T doesn't deserve
him to be in the top 50 ever it's
[__] asinine yeah
um
um Ozzy's on my album by the way free
Mozzy um free Mozzy
um okay so what's up with the Pusha T
gangster girls the center works is it
like started uh yes okay yeah is it
gonna come before or after this album he
keeps talking about it's gonna come
before his album oh so it's coming soon
yeah almost finished
uh I can't say that
I can't answer that did you guys kind of
are you looking at States yeah yeah
okay so literally what I'm doing I'm in
Kentucky yeah it wouldn't be Jack Harlow
hmm
wouldn't be
I'm just trying to think of like a
rapper that's hot right now from a
random [__] place
you know who it is no you don't
who could use a gangsta grills right now
who could use one I'll tell you who
could use against the grills
the baby could use against the grills
right now
shout out to the baby
it's not it
the baby could use an extra girls we've
talked
we've talked there's nobody from Utah
it's nobody from Vermont ah
all right listen you're gonna have to
just tell me off the [__] camera of
course
yeah once once the interview's over I'm
Missouri
who what other cities are in Missouri
what's that St Louis
um all right huh to be continued yeah
you got to think that's gonna [__] some
[__] up too like oh [__]
Dirk
hmm
Dirk Dirk has like three gangster girls
under his belt see I [__] I'm not a
little Dirk fan so I also like don't
like it's not like I'm not not a fan but
I'm also like I'm not like run into a
gangster girls from Little Dirk from I'm
sure what that was like 2012 13 14 like
yeah I'm just not interested at that
time to the streets shout out to uh to
Dirk though well listen man I appreciate
you pulling up the new albums coming in
April No 3 31. 3 30. oh [__] yeah it's
coming real soon yeah it's right it's on
the way can't wait to hear the Blasted
Nipsey song can't wait for you to hear
it can't wait for you to see this roll
out too I'm actually going to show you
after this interview
yeah and then another gangster girls
coming then another one
then uh then a possible Deluxe
have you and DJ Khaled ever screamed on
the same song Yes okay that's the last
thing yep we've screamed on the same
song which one which song was that we've
both been on uh raw song together
um we both were on a k slay song
Together rest in peace rest in peace the
case slay man yep I did the hook I think
Khalid wrapped
um I'm glad he stopped doing that what
rapping yeah yeah I mean it's kind of
dope though if you think about it
because then it gives you something to
perform when you have true fingers you
know what I'm saying what you think I'm
not full let's go up yeah yeah I mean it
was I you know if I could rap I would do
it you never rapped
um there's not recently though I've been
making my [__] ROM a little more no I'm
lying I had I did wait well I did a I
did a hook for scheme there's a scheme
record where I did the hook for oh and
then what happened to scheme
it's just been working
such a talented guy amazing talent
amazing talent we're going we're gonna
put something together shout out to
scheme yeah that's my brother I
appreciate you man uh 331 yeah I'm
really like that I'm really like that
you know new single out right now with
little baby and a boogie for me and uh
yeah let's end the interview so I get
the answer of this other [__] it's
gonna bother me DJ drunk holler at me
I'm really like that